good morning my name is David Bob I
serve as director of the Alan p Kirby
jr. center for constitutional studies
and citizenship at Hillsdale College
were here in Washington DC Hillsdale
College as many of you know was founded
in the 19th century in 1844 but we're
here today very much in this 21st
century spot before Hillsdale College
arrives at our building we've been
holding lectures and in particular this
lecture series at various places around
the city this morning we're delighted to
bring to you a topic of very timely
significance a supreme standard
constitutionalism and the Supreme Court
selection process is the topic very
Abele addressed by today's speaker and
you'll hear about more in just a moment
at Whelan has been doing a wonderful
work for those of you who don't know his
blog at bench memos and you should check
that out online a lot of coverage about
not just the current nomination contest
and deliberation but about a whole range
of judicial legal and indeed
constitutional issues of most importance
this is a regular lecture series the
first principles on First Fridays
lecture series will live up to its name
on the first principle side in July but
not on the first Friday because it
conflicts with the Independence Day
celebrations so on july nine Friday July
night we'll have our next lecture that
program will feature David Horowitz and
he's going to speak on the topic rules
for radicals what constitution
conservatives should know about Saul
Alinsky so you won't want to miss that
that's the same time 730am on friday
july nine you'll find out more
information a via email from the kirby
center or you can go to our website at
the kirby center for introducing our
speaker this morning is hillsdale
college student and kirby center intern
Amy Benjamin amy is majoring in art and
has a minor in history Amy our speaker
today ed Whelan is president of the
ethics and Public Policy Center a lawyer
and former law clerk to Supreme Court
Justice Antonin Scalia Whelan has served
as principal deputy assistant attorney
general for the Office of Legal Counsel
in the Department of Justice and as
general counsel to the US Senate
Committee on the judiciary he graduated
Phi Beta Kappa and with honors from
harvard college and received his JD
Magnum chrome law from Harvard Law
School where he was a member of the
board of editors for the Harvard Law
Review he is a frequent contributor to n
arose bench memos blog and our topic for
today is a supreme standard
constitutionalism and the Supreme Court
selection process please join me in
welcoming Whalen
I thanks Amy thank you David thanks to
all of you for being here thanks
especially to the kirby center for
conducting this excellent series here we
are in the midst of another Supreme
Court nomination this is the fourth
vacancy in the past five years all this
is occurring after an unusual 11 year
hiatus in which we had no vacancies that
was the longest such stretch since 1823
back in the days of the court of John
Marshall and of course we may well have
some more vacancies in the coming years
before too long passes now as with
recent nominations there's a flurry a
swirl of arguments and counting
arguments about whether Elena Kagan
should be confirmed about how the
Senators should conduct themselves about
whether she's qualified why she's
qualified why she's not qualified all
this can get rather dizzying and what I
hope to do today is step back and
explore first principles I in order to
help orient the question properly I'll
then discuss the kanga nomination and
elena kagan's record and apply these
principles to her nomination and
hopefully plenty of time for your
questions as well this begin with the
question what should a president look
for in a Supreme Court justice President
Obama has given his own answer to that
question that may be a useful place to
start he's giving his answer in his
notorious empathy standard now have in
mind that that President Obama's empathy
standard was not some offhand remark
that he made he articulated it first in
his carefully prepared floor statement
explaining why he was voting against the
confirmation of John Roberts to be Chief
Justice and what he said in that
statement is
is really remarkable he said that there
plenty of cases where everyone would
agree but there are other difficult
cases that can only be determined as the
quote on the basis of one's deepest
values one score concerns one's broader
perspectives on how the world works and
the depth and breadth of one's empathy
and pounding the point home he said in
those difficult cases the critical
ingredient is supplied by what is in the
judges heart not in the judge's mind is
applied to legal materials it's really
not legal materials out there but the
judge is hard in running for president
he again embraced this standard I very
similar language and a speech the
Planned Parenthood Action Fund for
example he said we need somebody who's
got the heart the empathy to recognize
what it's like to be a young teenage mom
the empathy to understand what it's like
to be poor or african-american or gay or
disabled or old and that's the criteria
by which I'll be selecting my judges all
right well not all right it's the clear
answer that the American people at given
and President Obama has been running
from his own empathy standard ever since
let's be clear there's nothing wrong
with empathy empathy properly understood
is of course a good thing and most of
the battles in the political arena
involves sorting out just what empathy
is and how it ought to be implemented in
in public policy but the traditional
virtue of judging is is is dispassion
not indulging empathy and what we see in
President Obama's empathy standard is a
really radical notion of what a Supreme
Court justice should be someone who is
indulging his or her own values in
defining what the Constitution means
inventing new rice when Obama talks
about difficult cases it's clear he's
talking about cases in which application
of traditional legal materials doesn't
yield the results that he wants some
cases are going mattered to him well
let's go back to them to
question what should the president look
for it in a justice and the answer to
that as we see with Obama is going to
turn on presidents understanding of what
the courts proper role is of course the
right answer turns on a a proper
understanding of what the courts role is
and questions we need to think about
here is is law distinct from politics if
it's not you know if as the left often
tells us law is just politics that why
not just pick a politician or or Oprah I
mean who better manifest the qualities
that President Obama was talking about
that Oprah is there such a thing as the
judicial craft and if so what is it
consistent how does a person develop the
skills that make a do digital craft and
how does the person manifest those
skills so the president can can identify
a hot here someone who's who's competent
well qualified to be on the Supreme
Court I think there are several possible
answers to that I would submit I'm a
judicial experience i think is first and
foremost the best way to to both develop
the judicial craft and to manifest it
and it's neither surprised nor anything
to be embarrassed about that all nine of
the current justices had previous do
digital experience before joining the
court now we can look at their their
records and i'm not sure that i was the
all in each case that their experience
we fully fall I've there's no doubt that
as as crafts then they have craftswomen
they have a certain level of a building
high level litigation is obviously
another way which one can develops on
the skills of the
important grappling with difficult
questions of federal law in positions in
the federal government and Office of
Legal Counsel for examples another
excellent excellent way and again it's
no surprise that former Chief Justice
Rehnquist Justice Scalia and Justice
Alito all had the experience in the
Office of Legal Counsel and serious
academic writing in which they're so
little but you know obviously is another
vehicle by which one can show and
develop the ability to grapple with
these difficult questions but when we're
asking about what the courts proper role
is another question beyond some sort of
objective measure of Kansas on
obstruction arguments is are there right
and wrong better and worse methods of
constitutional interpretation and that's
a question to which I like to devote a
good chunk of time here now a text of
the Constitution admittedly provides
little guidance on that question or on
these other questions are referred to
related to what a presidential look for
an injustice we know that the text says
the President shall nominate and by and
with the advice and consent of the
Senate shall appoint judges of the
Supreme Court we know also that the
judicial power of the United States have
a vested in one supreme court and the
judges shall hold their offices during
good behavior now we see it of course
that the Constitution is distinguishing
judicial power and executive power and
legislative power but these mere words
don't tell us much about how that power
is exercised what we need to do is
return to the underlying principles that
animate those provisions and I think a
good place to start is with Federalist
78 Alexander Hamilton the very document
which Hamilton was justifying the
exercise of judicial review the term we
lawyers use to talk about as just review
the power of the court to strike down
democratic enactments that violate the
Constitution here's what Hamilton had to
say
in that federal 78 it could be of no
wait to say that the courts on the
pretense of a repugnancy may substitute
their own pleasure to the constitutional
intense intentions at the legislature no
there's it's frivolous say that the
courts can just pretend that something
violates the Constitution the courts
must declare the sense of the law and if
they should be disposed to exercise will
instead of judgment the consequence
could equally be the substitution of
their pleasure to that of the
legislative body and then his kicker
conclusion the observation if approved
anything would prove that there ought be
there ought to be no judges distinct
from that body in other words if judges
are simply exercising their empathy
indulging their own sense of what's
right and wrong they have no warrant to
strike down legislation and they are
theirs they're basically defeating the
authority for their the very
justification for the role that they
have as Hamilton explains the power of
judicial review is ultimately rooted in
the power of the people as declared in
the Constitution now Hamilton's
proposition that the courts must declare
the sense of the law leaves naturally
the question of how the court should
determine that since that is the broader
question of judicial philosophy or as
Hamilton put it discerning the nature
and reason and how courts should carry
out their role which leads me to the
topic of originalism specifically
original meaning jurisprudence now the
term originalism sounds obscure and
dangerously exotic to the modern ear as
Justice Scalia has put it people ask him
when did you first become an original
'used unless the same tone and manner
they might use and ask him when he first
began eating human flesh
in fact there's good reason that the
term originalism is arcane the term
itself appears to be of recent vintage
from the 1980s now that's not because
there's anything novel about the
substance of originalism precisely the
opposite until recent decades
originalism had been so been challenged
in theory at least as constitutional
orthodoxy that there was no reason to
develop a term that would distinguish it
from an arrival as Justice Scalia has
put it in the past non-original opinions
have always had the decency to lie or
least to dissemble but what they were
doing but the express abandonment of
originalism in recent decades made
necessary a label for whatever one had
previously recognized as Elementary now
this sounds counterintuitive let me
offer a analogous semantic development
that I think illustrates the phenomenon
according to the Oxford English
Dictionary the term heterosexual came
the usage barely a century ago now
that's obviously not because
heterosexuals did not exist before then
rather it's precisely because what we
now call heterosexuality have been
widely understood to be normative so
what is originalism well succinctly
stated the term identifies the principal
with the meaning of various provisions
of the Constitution and of other laws
including statute enacted enacted a
statute enacted yesterday the meaning is
to be determined in accordance with a
sense de Bourgh at the time they were
promulgated I think that the common
sense intuitive appeal originalism may
be shown through an example let's take
the
the provision in the Constitution that
at least until the controversy over John
McCain's birth in the Panama Canal Zone
seemed well removed from the distorting
effects of political bias that's the
clause of the constitution that sets
forth by criteria to be eligible to
become president specifically I don't
want to refer to their first criterion
that one must be a natural born citizen
now that's an obscure phrase natural
born citizen as the protagonist in Ring
Lardner spaceball story says when he
runs across it on a draft registration
form I wonder what they think I am maybe
I think I fell out of a tree or
something now how should we go about
figuring out what the phrase Natural
Born This and means one approach which
might fairly be called current meaning
textualism would attempt to term of the
current meaning of the phrase and here
in this approach might note that we talk
these days about natural childbirth and
there's a seemingly linguistic
connection between natural born and
natural childbirth so maybe it follows
if your mother used at the girls or
other painkillers during her birth you
were not natural born and are not
eligible become president now a second
approach might draw the inspirations of
literature for its prey on the insides
of literature for inspiration and here
Shakespeare's Macbeth would seem to
offer particular help Macbeth finds
great comfort in the promise that none
of woman born shall harm him but his
comfort proves unwarranted when Macduff
who was from his mother's womb untimely
ripped kills Macbeth so under the
inspiration of this literary approach it
would followed anyone whose birth was by
sort of caesarean section is not a
natural born citizen now under a third
internationalist approach the judge
might determine that the natural born
citizen requirement whatever it means is
obviously a relic of a van iDEN
xenophobic past a past evolving
standards of decency as reflected in
modern transnational European electoral
practices requires be abandoned it
simply isn't fair this judge with the
clue
any candidate should be excluded by such
arbitrary requirement for running for
president the judge might have said
invoke the right to define one's own
concept of existence of meaning the
universe in the mystery of human life as
he instead substitutes his own arbitrary
criteria for eligibility that mystery
passage as I'm sure must have you
recognised is the passage that the
Supreme Court the authors of the joint
opinion in Planned Parenthood vkc relied
on in justifying their continued power
grout on the abortion issue the right to
the final ins own concept of existence
of meaning of the University of the
mystery of human life now a fourth
approach that of originalism would aim
to determine the meaning or intent or
understanding as an absolute one system
requirement to the time that phrase was
incorporated into the Constitution a
radically counter intuitive notion right
well if as I hope and suspect it's
obvious to you that this fourth
approaches the sound one next submit
that you are an original 'used and
striking that all the public discussion
over whether John McCain's birth in the
panel canal zone mentally isn't a
natural point citizen virtually all
commentators purported to undertake an
original inquiry whether or not they did
it well as a separate question but they
all try to look back and understand what
that term meant at the time was adopted
and the same intuition the same common
sense that you and others applies this
someone will pay but relatively
non-controversial provision of the
Constitution should apply to all the
other provisions now I strongly suspect
that many heterosexual English speakers
two or three generations ago dislike the
auditorium heterosexual we're not
particularly eager to have that label
apply to themselves but encourage you to
take delight in the term original list
knowing that it's soundly based and you
ought to have the same reaction that
Moliere's character did when he
discovered that he had been speaking in
prose all his life not even trying it's
really really delighted on that okay let
me turn then to the original meaning
species of originalism again my first
part my argument here is that
originalism is at the core of any sound
constitutional philosophy and any
president committed to the Constitution
I'd be looking for now there are
competing schools of originalism and
even within any particular school there
are important subsidiary methodological
issues I'm not going to get into but
that people have different views on that
can be sorted out but I think it's hard
to say that the original meaning
approach that Justice Scalia is
advocated is now dominant among original
asst and I just like to explain what
that approach is here's how Justice
Scalia stood forth in the District of
Columbia the Heller case the Second
Amendment ruling from from two years ago
in interpreting the Second Amendment he
said we are guided by the by the
principle that the Constitution is
written to be understood by the voters
it's words and Fraser used in their
normal and ordinary as distinguished of
technical meaning this general tenet
that excites is deeply rooted in the
American understanding Thomas Jefferson
as president wrote the Constitution on
which our union rest shall be
administered by me according to the safe
and honest meaning contemplated by the
plane understanding of the people of the
United States at the time of its
adoption Joseph's story the great
justice and constitutional scholar from
the early 19th century likewise observed
constitutions are not designed for
metaphysical or logical subtleties their
instruments of a practical nature found
on the common visit that human life
adapted to common law is designed for
common use and food for common
understandings that people make them
that people adopt them that people must
be supposed to read them with the help
of common sense
and Justice Scalia's opinion in DC
Heller i think is a excellent example of
the resources what looks to in
determining original public meaning
justice kill them what do 18th century
dictionaries contemporary contemporary
nested occupations of the constitution
other founding era sources state
constitutional provisions ratification
debates all things like that well i also
want to highlight that I think a very
interesting piece written recent years
my law professor Lawrence Solon that
shows that original meaning originalism
is he puts at Grandma both in common
sense and widely accepted theoretical
ideas about meaning and a nature of law
he grounds original meaning originalism
in the philosophy of language and
linguistics and how we communicate over
time I won't get into his more elaborate
argument here but I think when he says
that the common sense of originalism is
deeply rooted in how we understand
language now they've been a handful of
wealth lots of attacks on originalism
and I'm going to identify some of them
in order to clarify what original
meaning what the original meaning
methodology is one claim is that the
original meaning methodology leads to
conservative results well properly
applied the methodology leaves to
constitutionally incorrect results but I
want to emphasize that the claim that
leads to conservative results really
obscures quite a bit folks claim for
example to one author in The New Yorker
said it leads to conservative results at
least on social issues like abortion
capital punishment and gay rights that's
exactly wrong what's on all three of
those issues what originalism leads to
is the conclusion that those matters
abortion capital punishment and gay
rights our manners that the Constitution
doesn't address our matters that are
being worked out through the political
process is to reach whatever result the
people work out
in other words that the Constitution is
substantively neutral on those manners
it's not the case that you have original
is arguing that the Constitution
prohibits the democratic enactment of
same-sex marriage for example or the
Constitution requires that the death
penalty be administered in a certain
class of cases or that the Constitution
forbids permissive abortion laws on all
those matters and on the original asst
occupy the middle ground say the
Constitution is substi- tral and it's
the the left that is entrenched its use
in the Constitution and there's not an
effort counter effort to entrench
conservative views in the Constitution
there's also the claim equally aberrant
lists that originalism lacks flexibility
needed to adapt to changing
circumstances this is the claim made by
typically by proponents the so-called
living Constitution that is that make it
up as you go along approach and what's
really striking about it is how it
ignores well basically under originalism
the Constitution to abroad played the
democratic processes to for example
enact permissive abortion laws and to
say wait a sec that's been a real
mistake we ought to have the
prohibitions to to adapt over time to
changing circumstances it's it's the
living Constitution in this modern
insistence on entrenching the left's
agenda and the guise of constitutional
rights and then claiming at starry
decisis adherence the precedent is
sacrosanct that prevents the flexibility
over time it prevents the democratic
processes which I goofily made a mistake
let's revisit this and a third objection
to originalism is that it doesn't
provide answers to all questions well
this objection is subtly correct
originalism doesn't provide answers to
all questions but it's recasting a fatal
vice of non originalism
as though it's a virtue of course if
you're a living constitutionalist in the
Constitution means whatever you you want
to mean you'll have an answer to every
question what do I want well you know
what do I think is you know which
direction is history taking us I mean
you can have your answer different
different folks may different living
constitutionalist may have different
views but I it is the case that that
originalism will sometimes not have
clear answers to sort of questions that
are presented that's why original is the
needs to be supplemented by principles
of judicial restraint as I'll discuss
next but it's not it's not a flaw in
original in itself but what I mean by
judicial restraint there's supplemental
principle that I think needs to a
company or originalism well the core
principle is a judge's simply have no
authority to override a democratically
Nachman if their interpretive
methodology fails to make it
sufficiently clear an enactment is
unconstitutional if you really can't
tell you look hard and you can't tell
whether a statute violates the
Constitution the judges obligation is to
get the heck out of the way and I will
emphasize judicial restraint and
sometimes confused with simply adhering
to precedent and sorry decisis or
adherence to president has an important
role to play in a way of judges carry
out their obligations day-to-day I
compare it to you know when you're going
don't go out here your garage every day
you don't have to disassemble your car
and then reassemble it you can assume it
usually assume this in working order but
you know if you've been going out to
your your your your car in the morning
and it's smoking like crazy and try to
start it doesn't go anywhere maybe it's
time to reconsider things and I think
the best example of the case that
desperately needs revisiting is roe
versus wade the case it has 4 137 years
now corrupted our national politics
remove this contentious
issue from the democratic processes
where it belongs and you know as has
really warped the way public life is
carried out so let me sum up then on the
president's rule I think the president
has an obligation to form a sound
judicial philosophy and have that
judicial philosophy be an important part
of his selection of a Supreme Court
justice now how should the Senate carry
out its advice and consent role look
again the Constitution provides little
adult guidance office I think senators
in theory could vote up virtually any
basis it's worth noting that the modern
process that we take for granted sent
Judiciary Committee hearing is
relatively novel the first questioning
by senators took place in 1925 and then
occur again until 1939 but there are I
think it's fair to say to basic
computing models on the substance of the
Senate's role one model is one of
deference to the president sutton's some
versions complete deference others very
extensive here that often go to claim
that if someone is up is objectively
qualified the only question is whether
they are outside the mainstream or both
these terms I'm technically qualified
outside the mainstream smuggling in
notions that that are I think highly
contestable the second model is
involving strong focus on judicial
philosophy and insistence that someone
who occupies that important role of
Supreme Court justice have a judicial
philosophy that that indicates that
person will be faithful to the
Constitution interestingly enough Elena
Kagan herself embraced the view that
judicial philosophy ought to be central
to the sentence consideration of a
Supreme Court nominee so back in a 1995
article on article
reviewed that many the White House are
trying to run away from she had she had
this to say when the Senate ceases to
engage nominees and meaningful
discussion of legal issues confirmation
process takes on air at vacuity and
farce and instead it becomes incapable
of either properly evaluating nominees
for appropriately educating the public
further the kind of inquiry that will
contribute most to understanding and
evaluating a nomination is discussion
first of the nominees broad judicial
philosophy and second of her views on
particular constitutional questions
Kagan complains that responses to
questions on judicial philosophy
generally had become classic to do this
that's why she insists on the second
aspect of the inquiry the insistence on
seeing how theory works in practice by
evoking an ominous comments on
particular issues involving involving
privacy rights free speech race and
gender discrimination and so forth that
the court regularly faces now I'd submit
that there's nothing favorable that can
be said in theory about the deference
model again if if you agree as I do as
I'm maintaining that judicial philosophy
I'll be central to the president's
selection role how is it that the Senate
should be considering this as well now
there are possible practical defenses of
the difference model indeed if we lived
in a legal culture in which there are no
meaningful disputes about judicial
philosophy then
you know we could well trust that the
president was making was picking someone
about a sound understanding you just
look look to secondary factors likewise
if we knew we had a president who had a
sound understanding of judicial
philosophy and picking his nominees
deference might well be appropriate it's
quite possible that some senators might
think that the Senate is institutionally
incompetent to explore judicial
philosophy unfortunately there's some
empirical data to support that but i
don't think that theory explains the
sentence course of conduct nor i think
does it excuse senators from making sure
that they develop the competence to to
address these questions perhaps the most
serious practical argument for the
deference model is the claim that it's
needed to protect judicial independence
often as clay never goes beyond just
slogan and say the where general claims
of judicial independence and Elena Kagan
herself in her and her piece complain
that the term judicial independence was
often used in a fuzzy and inflated way
and that life tenure and the other the
other protections that the Constitution
gives the judges were for adequate
assurance of judicial independence but
you know a series compeers stuart taylor
recently wrote that in defense of the
deference model that this model is
needed to avoid forcing nominees to make
the moral equivalent of campaign
promises that would compromise both
their own integrity and independence of
the judiciary serious you know
a serious objection I think it falters
in the end for cultural reasons one you
have these these Supreme Court nominees
having closed-door meetings with
senators all the time and then
oftentimes senators will come out and
say oh I've just got an assurance on
this issue that matters to me well how
can we you know how could someone
tolerate that and then object to a
transparent discussion and I'd much
rather have any seeming in any deals
occur in public rather than behind
closed doors beyond that I think nominee
is a perfectly capable of making clear
look here's my current view based on
here's what I meant when I wrote this
three years ago but obviously i'm open
to to to to reconsider things and i
think you can have an open discussion
along a line going to Lena Kagan back in
1995 I believe very much the same thing
now it's striking that there's been a
real asymmetry long been a symmetry
between the way Republicans and
Democrats approach Supreme Court
confirmations since the Borg battle or
arguably even a year earlier with the
rehnquist elevation to Chief Justice
1986 Democrats they've tried to make
judicial philosophy at the centerpiece
of their objection to nominees at a time
after time after time now you know it so
I so I give them credit for being right
on the big question a bit judicial
philosophy relevant they're wrong in
having a completely wrong understanding
of judicial philosophy and secondarily
in using attacks invented attacks on
racism sexy and sexism and all these
other things do to to try and ethical
attacks to try to show that someone is
unqualified but it's striking that all
the way back
yeah again for more than 20 years
Democrats have made judicial philosophy
the heart of their battle against
nominees Republicans didn't do that I
mean I worked for Senator hatch in
1993-94 when justices Ginsburg and briar
or confirmed Justice Ginsburg was
confirmed 96 2 3gs Breyer 87 29 the
confirmation hearings or virtual love
fest with even Strom Thurmond saying Oh
to Justice Ginsburg loves you don't you
don't have to answer that question if
you don't want to and I think I think
it's interesting to to ponder why
Republicans persisted in this position
of different of deference to picking
seven opposite party president even
after seemed clear that the Democrats
weren't going to be taking that same
approach now one possible explanation is
that Republicans have made a strategic
that that the deference model would deal
better justices that is in particular
they thought oh well the Senate is
usually be dominated by Democrats
Republicans have a better chance of
getting control the presidency so if we
if we have if you're able to establish
this deference model pics of Republican
presidents will be deferred to by
Democrats it's be a sensible enough
theory to pursue I think it approved
wrong flight 93 and 94 and I would
suggest that unfortunately instead what
may have affected a lot of Republican
senators was that it was a lot easier a
lot more in their self-interest who
simply lie down and play dead on Supreme
Court on
and I think if we use a model of if we
looked at Public Choice Tyrion look at a
model of a senator's incentives you can
see that you don't have a mobilized base
driving you in one direction I said I
could say look the easiest path to
re-election involves no controversy
involved and voting against someone's
straight way to generate controversy and
if I can find a reason to vote for this
person of the opposite party I can
placate my base by invoking this
principle of deference to the president
I can present myself as a as a
reasonable centrists to any one of the
other side would want to I run against
me your vote or vote for my opponent and
I I think you know I I offer that as a
as a partial theory for Republican
persistence in the deference model well
I pleased to say that I think the
Sotomayor confirmation process last year
shows that Republicans put judicial
philosophy front and center obviously
they were in a definite minority but i
think that the process more than that of
any other in a long time i think is
really a model of how concerns about
judicial philosophy ought to dominate
the process that hearing was done the
respectful way we can all you know which
certain questions were asked you know in
better ways i'm not saying it was ideal
but i do think that that Republicans
weren't hiding behind in principle
difference the president most of the
morning and we're instead engaging in a
serious exploration of how it justice
Sotomayor 'but act on the court and of
course you have justice of my Sotomayor
trying to camouflage yourself as some
sort of traditional conservatives in a
way that's not really implausible and
you ended up with 3131 negative votes
against her so I think
in many ways would say I think it
represents a repudiation of the
deference model so I very briefly on
nominees on role in the process I think
Elena Kagan said it best in 1985 Law
Review piece speaking of Ginsberg and
briar she said I suspect that both
appreciate it for them as for most the
safest and surest route to the prize the
prize it is a confirmation lay in
alternating platitudinous statement and
judicial silence who would have been
anything different in the absence of
pressure for members of Congress so the
challenge the obligation of senators is
to engage in a thorough review of the
nominees record including an examination
judicial philosophy and it's we hope
will see more that in the coming
nomination coming hearing let me talk a
bit about elena kagan's record and
hopefully some time for your questions I
think it's clear that Obama's empathy
standard is part of parcel of his effort
to remake America in His image as he
pursues projects it's just sweeping
health care reform or rumination however
you will see it it's clear that he wants
justices will ignore constitutional
limits that stand in his way at the same
time he wants justices who will invent
new constitutional rights on matters
such as same-sex marriage that
permanently impose the agenda the left
now Elena Kagan has in many respects a
very scanty record very very limited
experience it's actually relevant to the
role of the Supreme Court 0 judicial
experience I'm not saying judicial
experience is a necessity I am saying
it's the best training and that it's
its lack is a deficiency that needs to
be compensated for by something else
she's only a few years of real-world
legal experience she had never argued an
appeal anywhere before becoming
Solicitor General last year during her
entire career in academia she's
generated only a handful of scholarly
articles which one liberal law professor
critic summarized as cautious academic
exercise and a sort of banal on the
other handing as on one hand on the
other hand whose prime virtue is it's
unlikely to offend anyone a position of
power Kagan has been remarkably guarded
about expressing her political and legal
views over the last couple decades one
person who knows her well I said he
doesn't know anyone who's had a
conversation with her and she expressed
a personal conviction on a question of
constitutional law in the past decade
but don't don't conclude from this that
she's anything other than creature the
left that the pattern is there when when
when we see her videos they're quite
clear all the way back to election I in
1980 when she she wrote in her student
newspaper at Princeton her despair the
takeover of the Senate by Republican
Avengers of innocent life and her her
you know she was she she wondered you
know what could possibly have happened
the world got mad should she rather her
senior thesis at Princeton on history of
socialism in New York City and no I'm
not arguing that writing a thesis on
history of socials in the New York City
means if someone's a socialist I will
point out though that she that she found
it puzzling as something that cries out
for explanation that Americans have more
likely to speak of capitalism's glories
than a socialism's greatness isn't it
puzzling they were not Americans are
hiding out sources of greatness
and she lamented the story of the
strange death of socialism in New York
City is what she called a sad but also a
chasing one for those who more than half
a century after socialism's decline
still wish to change America well I
think it's quite clear that she do that
as she herself you this sad she wrote a
couple years later I graduate thesis at
Oxford in which she said it was fine for
judges to bowl and steer the law mr.
quote in order to promote certain
ethical values and to achieve certain
social lands that they favor so long as
they cover up her decisions by which he
calls as long as they just could
plausibly be grounded in principle is
preferable to an acceptable source of
law which is clearly interested in there
is is making sure that you could
basically fool a Yahoo's out there by by
dressing up these rulings in legal
argument not actually apply sound method
interpretive methods to get the right
result but you know you figure out your
own division and see how you can
manipulate legal materials to seem to
justify where you want to get the white
house son is right to victim to declare
that she's clearly illegal progressive
she's lauded Justice Thurgood Marshall's
jurisprudence she was a law clerk for
him she said that Marshall Marshalls
view was the court had had freewheeling
authority quote to safeguard the
interests of people but no other
champion in these you said that the
court existed primarily to fulfill his
mission and she complained that some
some justices that sniped at marshalls
vision and the call today thing of glory
she lauded
judge Forks working as a model of a
serious discussion of the meaning of the
Constitution business as a model of how
a confirmation you ought to perceive
she's very lucky that that that her
critics are much higher standards than
that Ben Borges and that her process
will be would not be like that she's
criticized the ultimate wrongheadedness
of Justice Scalia's approach she's
called Ruth Bader Ginsburg a will not
moderate and there's this Israeli just
our own Barack Judge Richard Posner has
said without a secure constitutional
basis created a degree of dual power and
dreamt up by our most aggressive Supreme
Court justices and who has rulings on
important issues like standing you know
who can who can pursue a legal claim in
court that by American standards are
just crazy well Elena Kagan has
proclaimed him quote my judicial hero
and again his lavish timnath with praise
let me highlight one issue that got some
attention so far try to put in proper
context this is elena kagan's course of
conduct on the Solomon amendment this is
the 11 issue on what she has engaged in
vehement rhetoric and she condemned
Don't Ask Don't Tell as a profound wrong
a moral and justice of the first order I
would thought that genocide and things
that makes sure be morally justice is
the first order and that Don't Ask Don't
Tell be something at which reasonable
people have different views but but when
she became a Dean in 2003 she followed
the course of action that a predecessor
had established the year before under
pressure
sorry of giving military recruiters
access to the law school jobs office
while sending letters to the law school
community condemning them one year later
though after after a federal court ruled
that the Soliman that the Solomon
amendment was unconstitutional she saw
an opening to be more aggressive I
should make clear at solon amendment was
a measure that Congress adopted to
basically help implement Don't Ask Don't
Tell up said two universities if you
don't give military recruiters equal
access on your campuses you may be
disqualified from receiving federal
funds well even though this this federal
court ruling never became legally
effective even though the Supreme Court
grand review Kagan use this as an excuse
to kick military recruiters off campus
and her defenders try to say oh well the
recruiters she kicked him out of jobs
officer defender say oh well the
recruiters could still use a student
veterans association to organize their
interviews it's quite clear as the
Veterans Association is made it has it
has said that they did not have a
resources to come anywhere close to
replicating the services of the jobs
office and Kagan also vents under name
to an amicus brief in the Supreme Court
case where her position was unanimously
rejected by the Supreme Court so when
some what we have here is an exercise
that cheap moral posturing Kagan
elevated her ideological commitment on
gay rights above a Congress acting on
the advice of military leaders that
determined best serve the interests of
national security she directed her
verbal fire entirely the military not at
the politicians who in fact for ultimate
responsibility of Don't Ask Don't Tell
not at her former boss President Clinton
of assignment into into law the measure
that gave rise to Don't Ask Don't Tell
in the midst of war she violated the
solemn amendment by treating military
recruiters worse than she treated the
elite law firms there
donating their services to anti American
terrorists and suspected terrorists and
it is pure a biner the liberal film
editor of the New Republic has put it
barring military recruiters from the
jobs office amounted to quote a
statement of national estrangement close
called Kagan's quote alienating herself
from the country it's also want to
emphasize worth noting that the Khagan
had appeared to have indulged
ideological bias on gay rights Addison
Solicitor General by undermining the
federal laws of cheese was duty-bound to
defend now we often hear and I think
with the point is often well taken that
when keg and a solicitor general defends
a federal law that's her jobs you can't
you can't imputed her agreement with
that federal law well here it was her
obligation offer a vigorous defense of
the Defense of Marriage axonal in these
cases and Don't Ask Don't Tell in
another and she didn't do it she failed
to seek a Supreme Court review of a robe
Ninth Circuit ruling that threatened
Don't Ask Don't Tell and subjected the
military too burdensome litigation and
into her charge the Department of
Justice filed a brief that gratuitously
abandons drawn grounds for defending the
Defense of Marriage Act one component of
same-sex marriage celebrated the brief
as a gift to the gay marriage movement
that would no doubt make its way into
judicial opinions okay so let me be
brief years as we're running short on
time we'll make sure you have time for
questions but how should the Senate act
well I think it's quite clear that
there's nothing elena kagan's record to
indicate that she has a sound judicial
philosophy I think her even on objective
experience or record is is it is is
marginal precisely because Silva those
know about her legal and policy views
and because what little is known
suggests that she may indulge your sense
of empathy and making legal judgments
it's especially important to Senate
conduct a thorough examination
news and the burden should be on her to
his doubts if she's not quality is
qualified there's not is she no
deference son especially here we have a
president who's acting under a patently
irresponsible standard and the nominee
whose record gives no signs that she
understands what it means to be a
Supreme Court justice thank you looks
like we have a roving microphone so i
think you raise your hand and the mic
will come to you extremely enlightening
speech question about here there was a
time i think when the senate didn't hold
hearings with nominees and now trust
there they were your what has changed
what purpose we think hearings serve
well again you're right there are no
hearings for the 20s and irregular are
even after that what purpose do hearing
serve i guess that question can be
answered in perhaps two different ways
what what purpose should they serve and
what do they actually do I think
unfortunately in terms of what we
actually do hearings are television time
for senators and it could be a time
simply to politic and I think this is
like because a comment has bipartisan
application you know being okay here's
my comment I want to get my 15 seconds
of my local news asking a question I
think it could be able for concern to to
my constituents or I want to rate this
nominee so people will understand why it
is that I'm voting against the nominee
the hearing of course is in many ways
this the culmination seeming seeming
culmination a confirmation process the
the opportunity for the nominee to speak
out and actually address some of the
charges in some cases I was the best
false charges that have raised about
nominees and I think it serves an
important goal there i think john
roberts and Alito both were able to use
it very well to show that they were not
what they had been falsely portrayed to
be I think Sonia Sotomayor did exactly
opposite last year disguising her views
I'm hearing her answers on on the role
of foreign law and considering the
Constitution ship and national scandal
you know in Apple reason for anyone to
vote against her but what should is what
should hearing be the hearing ought to
be a serious exploration of opposition
philosophy it ought to be at a time when
senators engage and ask ask questions
and listen to the answers and do
intelligent follow-up and and show that
they have an understanding of the proper
role of course assistant represented
government and sure that they're serious
about making sure that the justices do
the hearings are tough it's a tough
environment the rounds can be so short
and unfortunately there's so many
senators I think the bipartisan comment
who are so used to hearing themselves
talk that they think that it's perfectly
proper to fill up their 15 minutes with
12 minutes of speechifying that they can
do at any other time where what they
ought to have is a series of crisp
questions that have it thought about the
forehand actually run through minute of
the nominees go through these woot
courts or murder boards how many
senators do you think ever do I'm you
know I guess the number is very low so
there's lots of room to improve the way
the hearings are conducted but I do
think that I do think the hearing has an
important role and a challenge here is
to is to uh to make better use of the
opportunity yes in the discussion of
regionalism left often brings up Plessy
versus Ferguson what if you'd come in
the interaction originalism and that
decision case obviously Brown versus
Board of Education sure well the less
standard are there suppose a big stick
to be originalism is is that that their
argue their claim is that the result in
Brown versus Board can't be justified in
original his crayons and they seem so
interested in establishing that
Morrison's outstanding and understanding
originalism look there have been some
very serious original asst
justifications for brown it have been
offered Mike McConnell and you know as
it has offered one and you know we can
examine those and see whether you find
them convincing or not if you don't find
in convincing I've submitted that that
that the logical conclusion is of the
problems 14th amendment that is if you
think the Fourteenth Amendment properly
construed according to original list
principles doesn't doesn't prohibit
state and forest segregation then your
complaint ought to be about the
Fourteenth Amendment plus he of course
was the decision in the eighteen ninety
the kinetics exactly that upheld
segregation state
mitted segregation and busters street
cars or trains and forgiving exactly
which and in many ways what you see in
brown was this excessive deference to
precedent because with the court you
know it's often said Oh Brown overruled
plastic we look at brown brown doesn't
say we overrule Plessy Brown said the
question in this case is whether the
rule of Plessy extends to public
education and we rule that it doesn't
and it is so you know it it's committing
the same flaw of not reading its own
precedent and taking its own precedent
as sacrosanct of course the first
Justice Harlan had a had a wonderful
dissent in Plessy that relied on his
understanding of the original public
meaning of the post Civil War amendments
to it's a very different conclusion so
you know I think that the resort to
brown argue against originalism is
flawed on multiple rounds
recently there big number of cases where
the religious freedom person ever
brighter religious freedom confluence
with the anti-discrimination laws case
for era in Council in a counseling
program that College refused to counsel
a gay couple our marriage and she was
sold out of the program and she sued to
get reinstated the program singer
released rights finally in these kinds
of cases according to what the
distinction made between empathy and
originalism how would the justices just
decide that one right over overcame
another or why we religious freedom
fetus is important in that case as
anti-discrimination well let me try to
address that in the abstract I would say
it's not the proper role the justice is
to try to mediate competing values in
the Constitution the question is whether
an enactment violates a command of the
Constitution does it should be
invalidated it doesn't even if even if
the enactment is something that we find
offensive the Justice finds offensive
just adjusted needs to let stand and the
obligation then is for us to work
through the political processes to fix
those laws now I don't mean to take any
any position offer any of you in cases
your you're referring to I think when
you have I think what happens in a lot
of cases if you have these the public
accommodations laws that have been
construed very very expensively by the
courts in a way no one ever imagined and
that's a lot of what's created the class
so
there may be different ways to to fix
that maybe as your question is asking
maybe there's a violation of
constitutional command if not you know
they're the political processes I in
that particular political jurisdiction
it could be employed to fix the problem
my name is Charlie kuhn and I years ago
and I worked on the hill and it's been
many many years since i took my
constitutional law class you'll have to
excuse me well we better off for having
it never having been many years ago
probably so is very very liberal but
anyway I become a real advocate of Mark
Levin and I really men in black for
about a third of time and as I recall he
makes a comment that judicial review was
an abridgment of the of the Constitution
and the separation of powers I mean I'm
not really sure if I understand what he
means by then judicial review what is it
good what is the Supreme Court supposed
to do and what are they doing in there
nice post well I'm not familiar with the
markets argument on this so I'm not
going to be responding to that I will
say that I think that it's a fairly
well-established just the Hamilton quote
that I cited indicated that that the
traditional understanding is that courts
would have the power in case it's
properly before them to say whether a
particular statute violated the
Constitution and I think
I think that the existence of that power
of judicial review is not what ought to
be objected to it's the manner in which
it has been so abused so wrongly
exercise and again it's been entirely
divorced from Hamels and saw as it's
essential founding in you know in the
sense of the language so that's I think
where where the focus needs to be and
this will be our final question it seems
like the Senate hearings came about
around the same time period as the 17th
amendment and do you think I just want
to offer any insight about the states
and states having representation in the
judicial selection process and Cynthia
revision of the federal estate is there
any large effects because of that it's
an interesting theory obviously once you
had a 17th amendment and the direct
election of senators and senators have
an incentive to respond more directly to
the people rather than to the state
legislatures and that would change the
way they carried out their jobs I would
think you know recent decades television
probably I was more to do with it but
but it may well be I think that the
initial initial hearing something so 9
25 26 was for Harlan Pistone who had
been attacked by some as it as a tool of
JP Morgan so it was populist attack on
him and hearing was an opportunity to to
to explore that for him to to counter
that
to be the tool the house of Morgan I can
only speculate beyond that I think that
lots of folks who are able to trace
various degradation Xin our political
process to the to the subjects and
evidence and I'm sympathetic to
two-sentence arguments haven't examined
closely enough myself job they hold on
well thank you all and appreciate being
here thank you very much and we
appreciate your time and let me remind
you once again that our next lecture
will be held on july nine david horowitz
and also that one of Ed Whelan's
colleagues and Senator Hatch's office
justice even markman who now sits on the
Michigan Supreme Court and teaches
constitutional law for Hillsdale College
has just published a white paper by the
Kirby centers first it explores the
theme of the coming constitutional
debate a debate that justice markman
warrants if citizens don't join it will
be settled within the ranks of legal
academia you can find that white paper
on the Kirby center's website the kirby
center or thank you very much for coming
you